hemos hecho bastantes vídeos acerca de
cómo encontrar la transformada de la
plaza pero en todos ellos ustedes se han
quedado quizás con la idea de bueno y
para que estoy aprendiendo esto ahora
les voy a mostrar por qué al menos en el
contexto de las ecuaciones diferenciales
de hecho hemos recibido bastante
correspondencia acerca de qué significa
realmente la transformada de la plaza y
aquí han hecho excelentes preguntas y
procuraré aquí responder a algunas de
ellas es difícil tener una intuición
acerca de la transformada de la plaza al
menos en el contexto de las ecuaciones
diferenciales además de ser una
herramienta bastante útil que nos ayuda
a convertir ecuaciones diferenciales en
operaciones algebraicas pero les voy a
dar aquí un tip si ustedes quieren
comprenderla mejor te recomiendo que
estudien transformada de fourier y las
series de fourier ya que son bastante
similares a esta transformada de la
plaza ahora vamos a usar la transformada
de la plaza para resolver una ecuación
diferencial y ésta ya la han visto antes
digamos que nuestra ecuación diferencial
es
y dos primas más 5 de prima
+ 6 porque y esto es igual a 0 y bueno
eso ustedes ya lo saben resolver pero
quería mostrarles una forma más directa
de resolver esto usando nuestras
transformadas de la plaza y las
condiciones iniciales son tiene 0 es
igual a 2
desde cero igualados de prima de cero
es igual a 3
y ahora
para poder usar la transformada de la
plaza tenemos que aplicar la
transformada de la plaza en ambos lados
de esta ecuación vamos a cambiar a un
color un poco más vibrante y tenemos la
transformada de la plaza
y dos primas más
esta parte de aquí es lo mismo que
escribir 5 por la transformada de la
plaza de prima
5 la transformada de la plaza de prima
más 6 por la transformada de la plaza de
james y déjeme preguntarles algo ustedes
saben cuál es la transformada de laplace
de 0 la integral de 0 a infinito
de 0 por el ala menos st dt
si es un 0 la transformada de la plaza 0
va a ser igual a 0 lo cual es muy bueno
porque ya no tengo espacio para escribir
otra l y aquí vamos a aplicar una de las
propiedades útiles que aprendimos en los
vídeos anteriores
la propiedad útil
que va a ocuparnos bastante espacio
vamos a quitar esto que nos estorba
así que bueno cuál es esta propiedad
misteriosa que vamos a usar
que voy a escribir aquí abajito la
transformada de la plaza de mi prima o
efe prima
es igual a ese multiplicado por la
transformada de la plaza de g - y
evaluada en 0 nosotros probamos esto en
un vídeo anterior para ver que
efectivamente ese es el resultado de la
transformada de la plaza y ahora vamos a
ver si podemos aplicar esto en nuestro
problema si aplicamos esto va a ser
igual a ese multiplicado por la
transformada de la plaza
si pasamos de prima hay en este otro
caso vamos a pasar de 2 prima a ye prima
así que nos queda de prima menos
primera derivada evaluada en 0 y aquí ya
tenemos este valor ya lo tenemos acá
ahora vamos a terminar con esta otra
parte vamos a sumar más 5
por la transformada de la plaza d
y prima
6 por la transformada de la plaza de g
de james igual a 0 y para aclarar todo
lo que hice fue sustituir esta parte por
esto usando esto y bueno ahora cómo
podemos reescribir está transformada de
la plaza pues usamos de nuevo esta
fórmula de aquí vamos a hacerlo ahora lo
voy a hacer en otro color en magenta ese
multiplicado
x está transformada de la plaza ya prima
que a su vez es ese por la transformada
de la plaza de g
- y de cero
todo esto está sustituyendo lo aquí
- que prima de 0
y ahora voy a cambiar de colores para
que sean poco más claro + 5
y ahora vamos a sustituir la
transformada de la clase prima va a ser
5 por s por la transformada de la plaza
de g
menos
y evaluado en cero
cerramos el paréntesis más 6 pone
transformadas de la plaza y aquí ya no
tengo espacio mejor lo pongo aquí abajo
más 6 por la transformada de la plaza
y esto es igual a cero sé que todo esto
puede parecer bastante confuso pero no
se preocupen ahorita vamos a
simplificarlo incluso ya podemos quitar
esta parte de acá
así que vamos a hacer algo de espacio
una nueva transformada de laplace no
tenemos que adivinar cuál es la solución
general ni nada por el estilo en cambio
ahora sólo vamos a tomar las informadas
de la plaza y vamos a ver hasta dónde
nos lleva esto
voy a aclarar un poco más esto
esto que voy a subrayar aquí
reescribir esta parte
esto de aquí
y reescribir esta otra parte como lo que
se encuentra aquí entre paréntesis todo
lo demás queda igual ahora simplificando
nos queda ese al cuadrado puede
transformar de la plaza de g
- sport evaluado en cero
vamos a sustituir de 0 90 es dos así que
nos queda 2s
primero y vemos que la prima de cero
estrés así que menos 12 s menos 3 más
5 por s multiplicado por esto
5 por s la transformada de la plaza de g
- 5 por 0 pero el 10 2 - 5 por 2 10
estamos sustituyendo el valor de 30 más
6 por la transformada de la plaza de yen
y todo esto es igual a cero
y ahora vamos a agrupar nuestros
términos de la transformada de la plaza
y nuestros términos constantes y
esperemos que todo esto nos lleve a
alguna parte veamos aquí voy a estar
subrayando los términos con transformada
de la plaza y tengo este tengo este y
tengo este otro
vamos a factorizar estos términos
tenemos la transformada de la plaza de g
lo que está bien para estar evitando nos
escribir esto una y otra vez lo vamos a
multiplicar por s cuadrada
5 s + 5 s
+ 6
todos estos son mis términos que tienen
una transformada de la plaza y ahora
tengo mis términos constantes menos 2s
- 3
menos 10 igual a 0 y ahora lo que
podemos hacer aquí
bueno aquí está algo interesante noten
que aquí tenemos que los coeficientes de
la transformada de la plaza los que
tienen los términos en que están en
formato de ecuación diferencial y no
sólo eso está exactamente con los mismos
coeficientes que nuestra educación
original lo que nos da una pista
importante y bueno si ustedes les
interesa encontrar conexiones algo tenue
pues bueno aquí hay una de ellas la
ecuación característica que obtuvimos lo
hicimos sustituyendo las transformadas
de la plaza y esas transformadas de la
plaza se involucran funciones bastante
similares pero de cualquier manera
regresemos a nuestro problema lo que voy
a hacer ahora es que voy a resolver esto
voy a decir bueno la transformada de la
plaza de iu es igual a algo y después
voy a buscar qué funciones de la
transformada de la plasmada en esto y
entonces ya habré encontrado la solución
si eso nos confundió no se preocupen
siguen observando porque a partir de
ahora vamos a tener un álgebra bastante
densa
así que vamos a hacer espacio aquí abajo
para tener un lugar donde describir y
aquí escribimos la transformada de la
plaza de y multiplicada por s cuadrada
más 5 s 6 y esos términos constantes los
voy a pasar de este otro lado de la
igualdad por lo que me queda 2 s más 3
más 10 bueno de hecho aquí sería 13 no
tiene caso dejarlo así
2 s 13
y ahora qué puedo hacer
bueno pues vamos a dividir ambos lados
de esta ecuación entre s cuadrada más 5
s más 6 de manera que la transformada de
la plaza de y me quede solita en un lado
de la ecuación y sea igual a 2 s 13
entre s cuadrada más 5 s más 6 y ya casi
estamos terminando ahora lo que tenemos
que hacer es encontrar qué función ya
tendría una transformada de la plaza
parecida a esto si nosotros tuviéramos
esto en nuestra tabla de transformadas
de la plaza pues podríamos encontrar de
inmediato cuál es la transformada que
corresponde pero realmente no tenemos
algo idéntico a esto en nuestra tabla de
transformadas y bueno mestre quedamos
sin tiempo en el siguiente vídeo vamos a
continuar resolviendo esta transformada
de la plaza y vamos a encontrar qué tipo
de transformada de la plaza tiene esta
función usando las cosas que ya sabemos
y manipulando esto algebraica mente nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo